speaking of great stand-up comedians
um
doug stanhope
put something up
he wrote something he's friends with uh
johnny depp and he's going through this
brutal [ __ ] divorce
and uh i just want to give him props
for sticking up for his friend and
everything and saying something because
you know you know what's really so
[ __ ] up
all right
it's all the [ __ ] that happens to women
that guys do women is [ __ ] up but
there has been a slight over correction
now where if somebody a woman just says
you do something
before you're ever tried or convicted it
just gets put in the paper it gets put
all over the internet and then all you
[ __ ] morons or 90 of you on the
[ __ ] internet
just take it as truth
take it as fun why do you take it as
truth
because you want it to be true because
he's doing better than you in life i
mean
it's [ __ ] unbelievable i i really
believe this okay if somebody gets
accused
okay
of of of rape or domestic violence they
should not publicize the person's name
until they're convicted of it i think
that's more than fair
considering all the [ __ ] dopes out
there that the second they read
something no it's gonna be true
you know
let it [ __ ]
see what happens first
see what the [ __ ] happens first oh that
that that whole thing now that all you
got to do is just say the amount of
[ __ ] guys who've been falsely accused
of that [ __ ] it's like you're literally
[ __ ] with their ability to get a job
you're [ __ ] with their reputation you
know the deal dude
like domestic violence and anything
involving sex that [ __ ] never goes that
never goes away
um
so i don't know i just want to you know
give stan hope [ __ ] props for
actually sticking up for the guy because
there's a lot of people
you know because of the stigma around
that even if they know it isn't true
they're afraid to throw their hat in the
[ __ ] ring
right now i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened or whatever okay i'm just
saying the fact that somebody finally
just said hey this guy hasn't been tried
for anything yet he's a friend of mine i
know he would never do this it was it
was refreshing to finally read that and
for somebody to finally say
you know what i believe is you shouldn't
put somebody's name out there until
you know 100 tried and convicted they
they definitely did that [ __ ] and then
if they did tar and feather them but to
do that to somebody
um
and also to give that weapon to somebody
that they can just [ __ ] say that
and blackmail you with that and and
really destroy your reputation
um
i don't know is is [ __ ] reprehensible
so there's another thing that isn't
really funny
you know
you know
it's like all those duke lacrosse
players
this [ __ ] they just [ __ ] faces all
over the [ __ ]
and you know to this day despite the
fact that they were totally vindicated
despite the fact that there was the 30
for 30 talking about how bad they got
railroaded despite all of that you know
that's still going to affect their lives
you know there's still going to be
somebody going uh yeah but you know
something happened you know somebody
when they get mad and they got nothing
else to say they're going to call him a
rapist or something like that you
[ __ ] know that they're going to
um
so i don't know
i don't know it was it was good to see
and of course it was stanhope stanhope
stanhope's a good [ __ ] man um
as is johnny depp by the way a few times
he's he's a big stand-up fan he comes
out to shows he's [ __ ] humble as hell
you know gentle one of the most gentle
[ __ ] people ever you know what i mean
look listen to me listen how the [ __ ] i
talk you know what i mean
you'd understand it if it came you know
somebody said that about me that he
[ __ ] snapped like posey and [ __ ]
dirty dozen
i know i barely know the guy i've only
met him a few [ __ ] times but like i
don't i i really
tend to believe
what the [ __ ]
stan hope is saying and i 100 believe
that you should not be putting
somebody's [ __ ] name out there just
because somebody said it
you know
oh it's [ __ ] um but this [ __ ]
state is brutal she's going for [ __ ]
spousal support you know going for
[ __ ] spousal support which means he's
got to pay her for like the rest of her
[ __ ] life she married the guy for 15
[ __ ] months and you know what kills
me about that person she's gonna [ __ ]
go to the beyonce concert right oh the
lady is the independent and she said
well you watch her throw a [ __ ] hand
up
oh that [ __ ] gets me heated all right
here we go here we go is there any
[ __ ] ribbons for from for guys
falsely accused of rape and domestic
violence you know is do they get that
month
you know will the nfl wear a color for
them of course they won't they don't
they don't give a [ __ ]
um anyways